can we take a moment please just take a
moment dazzling
you're married to her thank you i know
sometimes i look at these events and i
can't believe my luck
no i'm i'm with you i can't believe my
luck nominate it again did we know it
first time we met i mean that we know we
have the same birthday yes september
25th
oh now
i know so uh and i was just looking at
that thinking how lucky was i that
turned out to be the same day because
that was what did it really fate i love
it
like catherine mentioned you are
nominated tonight for the kaminsky
method this is like this show
it's just full of just
fun and yumminess and everything thank
you thank you yeah this was our final
year
uh it was originally just for two and he
really wanted to do it for the third
season and and um i'm just came from a
little jet like from london right now
we're off doing ant-man but i want to
come back we'll just support chuck
laurie's behind me and just what a
wonderful job
he did and paul ryser and all that you
know we got six nominations i love the
show i was really proud of it so it was
a nice
thank you so much emmy to some say
goodbye for the show i love that so much
and you're presenting tonight correct
yes indeed a drama which is a
that's a that's the big category that's
a big category there's a lot of great
guys in that category um but and a lot
of great performances i think just this
year you know with covet and everything
is we've had a chance to there's always
great performances but we've had a
little bit more time to really
appreciate some great some great turns
this year so i got to ask about these
jewels on your neck i'm sorry y'all
you're just staring so i saw you staring
at them
right i know i mean they're just
beautiful lorraine schwartz she really
knows how to do it and um
hey guys i got a birthday coming up
well honey i thought that was a lot
i was trying to lead you there she's got
a birthday card we
talked about this before it was all set
up it was all a set up you're also
playing more tisha adams too and
wednesday how's that going i am well i'm
just about to start shooting in in
romania i'm so excited to be to be
working with you know the great tim
burton and
and you know actually the makeup and and
costume designer who i've worked with
before so with luis goodman guzman
playing uh gomez who i worked with on
traffic is going to be really a
wonderful kind of camaraderie i'm really
looking forward to doing it
can't wait to see it and for you good
luck tonight sir
[Music]
you